Maelstrom,
who is apparently chaos
given the name asked me,
am I chaos or am I order?
Well,
that's a good question.
I would say a lot of the time I'm chaos,
but I do everything I can
to put things in order.
Um,
but I'm going to answer
that in a deeper way.
I would say,
because first of all,
everything and everyone is chaos
and order at the same time.
And I don't mean that in a trait sense.
I mean in a technical sense,
which is order.
Technically speaking in my way of viewing
the world is order is that domain you
inhabit when what you're doing produces
the results that you want to have
happen.
That's a pragmatic perspective from,
from a philosophical perspective,
it's derived at least in part or is it
analogous to the pragmatism of people
like,
um,
cs purse and William James,
the American PR,
the early American pragmatists.
Um,
and there's a great book on
all that if you're interested,
called the metaphysical club.
Um,
so order is where you are when what
you're doing is producing the results that
you intended and that
validates what you're doing.
By the way,
that that's a pragmatic form of truth.
Your theory is accurate when if you
enact it then the results that you intend
emerge.
That's the definition of truth.
From a pragmatic perspective,
it's a very powerful definition and it's
very much associated with the Darwinian
notion of truth.
So that's worth,
that's worth looking into.
Now obviously there are times when
you implement a plan and and at world
conception that goes along with that
plan and what you wanted didn't happen.
And so then the domain of chaos comes up,
the domain of the unpredictable
and unexpected and you
have to contend with it.
And sometimes when you are acting,
you do perverse things and things that
surprise you and then things don't work
out well for you.
Or maybe you get a surprise and maybe
sometimes that might even be positive and
that's because the chaos within new
as manifested itself and you've done
something that exceeds the bounds of
your understanding and you know that can
happen to people so badly that they
developed post traumatic stress,
posttraumatic stress disorder.
Sometimes soldiers,
especially naive young soldiers,
will go on a battlefield and watched
themselves do something they can't imagine
they're capable of doing and then they
have permanent post traumatic stress
disorder.
So there's a chaos within
that can manifest itself,
that can disrupt whatever order you are.
Um,
and you know that minor ways because
everybody's always running around doing
things that aren't good for them,
that they know they shouldn't
do and that they can't control.
And so there's a chaotic and an
orderly aspect to everything,
to the individual,
to the family,
to the social world,
to the natural world.
It's chaos and order at every
level of analysis simultaneously,
which is why the Dallas think of the
world is made out of Yin and Yang,
which is essentially,
um,
analogous to the idea of order and chaos.
And now,
but then there's another element too.
So your order and your chaos
and the place that you live,
the environment is
order and chaos as well.
But you're also the process
that mediates between the two.
And what that means is you're the forest
that confronts chaos and casts it into
order.
We talked about that in
the freewill discussion.
That's the basis for the dragon math,
or at least part of it,
the hero myth.
You are the forest that confronts chaos
and transforms it into habitable order.
And there's an idea that if you
do that using truthful speech,
it's probably the deepest
idea in the Bible.
If you confront chaos and the
unknown using truthful speech,
then the order that you produce is good.
So that also means that your chaos and
order and the process that intermediates
between them,
and that's really the
basis of the hero myth.
So part of that is the hero
story and the Dragon Myth.
Go Out,
confront the drag and get the gold,
bring it back,
share it with the community.
And the dragon is a representation of
that which dwells beyond the confines of
the safe and habitable space.
Right?
It's an image of a predator.
That's part of what it is.
Although it's way more
complicated than that.
And you're also the forest that confronts
order when it becomes too tyrannical
and restructures it back to chaos and
then restructures the chaos back into more
beneficial order,
which is what you do.
For example,
if you have an argument with
someone that you settle,
right?
Cause the argument takes the orderly,
um,
relation that you have with that person
and then produces a chaotic interlude,
which is all the pain that's
associated with the argument.
And that's a dissolution into what Mircea
Eliade called pre cosmic gone chaos.
And out of that,
a new order can emerge.
And so the best way to construe
yourself is not as chaos or as order,
but as the process that
mediates between the,
and that's the basis for the ethos of
the West is that the human being is best
represented as the individual and
the individual is that attentive and
communicative entity that is continually
capable of mediating properly between
chaos and order.
Now this is a deep idea.
You could read maps of
meaning if you would like.
The audio version of that
is coming out June 12th,
by the way.
And I will make a video detailing the
relationship between maps of meaning and
12 rules of life.
But you can construe yourself,
you should construe yourself as the
process that mediates between chaos and
order.
And you should aim to be the process
that does that properly using truthful
communication because that's how you
keep the elements of existence properly
balanced.
And you might say,
yeah,
but is that real?
Well,
if you read maps of meaning,
there's a section on
neuropsychology that's also
buttressed by a book written by
Ian Mcgilchrist called the master
and his emissary that lays out the
relationship between the right
and left hand Miss Hemisphere.
Now,
it's quite strange that we have
a right and left hemisphere.
It's almost as if we have two
consciousnesses dwelling in our,
in our,
in our being,
and they're quite separable.
If you cut the Corpus
callosum that unites the two,
then the two hemispheres will
act independently to some degree.
You can communicate with each
of them somewhat independently,
so they actually view the
world quite differently.
And that that hemisphere distinction
is not only they're human beings,
but also an animal's along way
down the phylogenetic chain.
Now,
I made the claim partly because I was
reading a man named m e l Conan Goldberg,
who was a student of Alexander Luria,
the most brilliant neuro
psychologist of the 20th century.
And Andy Goldberg made the case that,
um,
the left hemisphere is specialized for,
for what's known.
And the right hemisphere is specialized
for a normally and VSRM a Shondra and
who's a famous neurologist.
I'm an MD in,
in California has also made a very similar
claim based on his analysis of brain
damaged individuals.
But Goldberg's case was
the left hemisphere is
specialized for what you know,
how to do.
And the right hemisphere is specialized
for response to what's unknown and that
maps on to this order chaos dimension,
right,
and the right hemisphere.
Now,
um,
McGilchrist in his book,
the master and his emissary has
pointed out quite clearly that the left
hemisphere has a tyrannical tendency,
which Rameshchandra Shondra
and also viewed in his brain
damaged patients by the
way.
And that the left hemisphere
is always trying to impose.
It's logical and restricted
order on the world.
And to make the world fit into that.
Now it has to do that.
There's reasons for that.
Part of the reason is,
is that if your theory you've worked on
for 10 years makes one prediction error,
you shouldn't throw the
whole damn thing out.
You should doubt the prediction error,
right?
Cause you never know when your data is
actually data or is just another kind of
theory.
We can't get into that at the moment.
Now,
um,
McGilchrist makes it very strong case
and I think a more elaborated case than I
made in maps of meaning.
But it's the same argument fundamentally
that the right hemisphere is concerned
with reaction to anomaly.
And so,
so what happens in some senses
something unexpected happens.
That's the domain of chaos.
And that stops you in your tracks,
it freezes you.
And that's a Predator response.
A prey response.
Actually,
you're frozen,
the unknown has manifested itself.
You're not in order anymore.
You don't know where you are
and you don't know what to do.
And so,
and you can't just shut
down like a computer does.
You freeze instead.
And then what happens is that the
ancient mechanisms that have helped our
ancestors for tens of millions of years,
or perhaps longer than that,
react to that which looks beyond the
confines of the unknown kick in and you
start,
first of all,
that's motoric.
So you freeze and then you cautiously
start to explore and then it's imagistic.
You start making imaginal representations,
metaphoric representations,
dramatic representations of what
might constitute the unknown.
And then those representations are
practiced and implemented in the world.
They become more and more
fine grained and automatized.
And as that happens,
the locale that they're represented in
the brain shifts from right to left.
So,
so,
so the reason I'm telling you
all this is because you know,
this is where the metaphysical
and the physical unite,
and this is the sort of argument that
I was trying to make to Sam Harris.
And hopefully we'll be able to continue
doing that because I'm going to meet him
three times in the next few months.
Is that the,
the Yin Yang idea,
the chaos order ideas,
metaphorical in some sense to say that
the world is made up of order and chaos
doesn't sound like an empirical statement,
but strangely enough,
the world to which our brains are adapted
is actually the world of chaos and
order.
You can think about it as unexplored,
unexplored territory too.
That's another,
that's another,
you know,
take on it.
And so then you think from
a Darwinian perspective,
think about it this way.
From a Darwinian perspective,
there's an,
there's an an axiomatic presupposition,
and that is reality is that which selects,
okay,
reality is the force that
selects over evolutionary time.
And so the force that selects over
evolutionary time has selected for
hemispheric specialization,
bilateral hemispheric specialization,
which indicates the two different modes
of looking at the world are necessary
for survival,
right?
So that's real.
And so the idea that the world is made
out of chaos in order is perhaps the most
real idea.
Now,
here's something else cool
that's associated with that.
And this is an antidote to nihilism.
I also think it's an antidote to two.
What would you call 'em?
Ideological,
ideological possession.
So when you encounter something unknown,
you orient towards it and
that's an involuntary response.
You could even think about it
as a deterministic response.
It's part of what orients you
very rapidly towards predators.
So they don't kill you before
you have a chance to respond.
Okay,
so you react because the
anomalous thing is meaningful.
It's intrinsically meaningful.
And the reaction is first terror with
perhaps an overlay of disgust and second
curiosity.
And it's terrorist so that you
freeze and remain paralyzed.
You turn to stone.
When you look at the Bass Lisk
or the snake or the Gorgon,
you turned to stone.
You're paralyzed like a prey animal.
And that's so the prey Predator
can't see you at least in part.
And there's other elements
of the orienting reflects
that are associated with
Predator avoidance.
And then if nothing
additionally terrible happens,
you start to thaw out
and you start to explore.
And you do that with image first and,
and then PR and then practice the
appropriate behaviors and then,
and then automate those.
Now look,
here's the thing.
That's cool.
So that orienting reflects to the
unknown is it's an admixture of threat,
fear and curiosity,
incentive reward.
So negative emotion and positive
emotion now and it's dose dependent.
The larger the anomaly,
which means the larger the map,
it blows out when it manifests itself.
Think of the difference between being
irritated at your marital partner because
they,
you know,
um Oh,
who knows?
Because they were late to pick you up
for work compared to how we rotated you
would be if you found out
they were having an affair.
Difference in size of a,
normally the first one disrupts
a tiny little part of your space,
time orientation and the second
one demolishes your past,
present and future.
And the larger the disruption,
the more negative emotion obviously.
And so,
so there's this weird interplay between
negative and positive emotion in the
response to a normally and,
but it's deeply meaningful,
even if it's even if it paralyzes you,
even if it's terrifying,
it's meaningful.
And then that transforms perhaps into
intense curiosity and you start to
explore.
Now the phenomena of meaning
is a manifestation of the
complex orienting reflex.
And so you're wired so that you're not
just order and you're not just chaos,
your order continually confronting
chaos so that the order remains updated.
And you might say,
well,
how do you know how much chaos you should
confront in order to keep the order
continually updated?
And the answer is maybe see
something is meaningful.
The reason that something is meaningful
is because you're getting a deep
instinctual signal that
you're encountering a normally
at a rate that doesn't
exceed your capability.
That's also the rate at which you
can keep yourself updated optimally.
And so meaning isn't
epit phenomenal and it,
and it isn't.
It isn't some kind of delusion
that rationality can and
should overcome to say,
well,
everything's meaningless.
It's like,
no,
it's not.
Meaning is the most fundamental
instinct for adaptation.
And so that's partly why
in 12 rules for life.
I said one of the rules,
I think it's rule seven
is do what is meaningful,
not what is expedient because meaning
is a really good guide to longterm
adaptation.
And so then,
and the other thing about meaning,
which is what happens when you get
the balance between chaos and order,
right?
Is that meaning is the
antidote to despair.
And so if you,
and there's all sorts of
reasons in life to be desperate.
And so if you immerse yourself in meaning,
you can learn to do that.
You can learn to do that.
You can make that goal your highest goal.
And so then the highest goal would be
to be the sort of mythological hero,
let's say,
to embody and incarnate and
imitate the mythological hero,
like the imitation of Christ,
which is what you're called to do.
If you happen to be Christian,
that means that you live in meaning.
And that meaning is the antidote to the
suffering of life that would otherwise
make you brutal and vengeful
and unhappy and miserable.
And like that,
that young guy who just mowed
down 12 people in Toronto,
these are real things.
You lose your sense of meaning.
You end up in hell and inhale,
you do all sorts of terrible things.
These are,
these are dreadful realities and it
isn't as if they're not grounded in the
appropriate science.